foreign
people we are live from the swamp one
more time that's right I am on location
in Washington DC did we pick the right
week to come to DC or what I mean
everyone and their brother is here
obviously the house is voting on the
leadership and the Senate's trying to
figure that stuff out I don't know if
you heard about it but Donald J Trump is
going to run for president again it's
it's actually crazy in this town right
now it's funny because we got here a
couple days ago uh it was pretty much
dead like a like a zombie apocalypse
where is everybody in the city movie and
now everybody's here kind of nutty oh
I'm Dave Rubin and this is the Reuben
report and it's November 17 2022 and
we're live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and Blaze TV uh and today we have a
Reuben report.locals.com Community Q a
for you uh I did want to start though uh
taking us out of the United States of
America because you know it can be a
little myopic only focusing on our
problems here but other countries do
have problems there are other
politicians who are not very respectful
of individual liberty and you know
freedom things like that so it is good
when we talk about them so I'm going to
do something up top about Justin Trudeau
and I actually can link it to what's
going on here in the United States
because his authoritarianism is not
stopping in Canada and I think it's
exactly the same authoritarianism we're
going to be seeing more and more of in
blue States post this election where a
whole bunch of people decided that they
wanted to keep Gretchen Whitmer in
Michigan and Kathy hochel in New York
and Gavin Newsom and Cali and we're just
going to see a I would say a widening of
life and Lifestyles when it comes to
living in a blue State at a Red State
and then we'll get to the questions and
then I'm off to the fox Patriot Awards
in Hollywood Florida doing Gutfeld on
Friday and I'll see who else I can chat
with over there real quick guys let me
talk to you about kamikoto knives you
know it's time to up your kitchen knife
game using kamikoto knives using
traditional techniques kamikoto crafts
beautiful knives using steel Source from
Japan each blade is made with techniques
that have been honed and perfected by
generations of knife Smiths they come in
a beautiful heavy duty Ash wood box and
every blade is individually inspected
and comes with a like lifetime guarantee
because of their single bevel Edge
kamikoto knives can achieve a wickedly
sharp edge the kind you just can't get
with other knives these are cut through
your rib eye like butter sharp kamikoto
knives are used by several chefs working
for Michelin star restaurants around the
world they make amazing gifts that come
in beautiful boxes you can maintain each
knives edge with one of kamikoto's
sharpening wet stones and like I said
they're so confident in their product
that each and every knife comes with a
lifetime guarantee if you go ahead and
buy now kamikodo's offering you an extra
fifty dollars off site-wide on top of
their Black Friday sale go to
commiekoto.com Reuben and use the offer
code Reuben for an extra 50 bucks off
that's
k-a-m-i-k-o-t-o.com slash
reubencomicoto.com
slash Reuben all right let's talk about
Justin Trudeau for a little bit because
you know when we do these Community Q
and A's I always like to tee it off with
the story and obviously I could do more
about Trump and we could talk about
DeSantis and we could talk about Mitch
McConnell and everything going on here
and Kevin McCarthy and all the upheaval
and all that stuff but there is another
world out there outside of the United
States Believe It or Not Americans uh
and unfortunately Justin Trudeau who you
guys know he was just one of the if
perhaps the worst Western world leader
when it came to lockdowns and looking at
people's bank accounts remember the
Canadian Truckers when they were
protesting him and forcing vaxes and
just all of this stuff well Trudeau is
not given up on any of it he's actually
continuing it and he still wants people
to get boosted and vaxxed and a whole
bunch more and you're not going to
believe it that kinda helps him keep a
state of emergency going so that he can
infringe on people's rights wacky stuff
I know Justin Trudeau and just on
matters back home we're watching cost
fertilization rates Skyrocket at the
moment Ontario is going to start urging
people to publicly wear masks again are
you considering bringing back Federal
public Mass mandates the single best
thing Canadians can do
to prevent our hospitals from getting
overwhelmed to keep themselves and their
loved ones safe during the coming winter
months
is to make sure your vaccinations are up
to date
please like I did just a few days ago
get your booster for covid-19 get your
flu shot at the same time make sure your
kids get boosted
oh lord well look uh I sympathize and
empathize with those of you that live
under the uh
the veil under the shadow under the foot
of Justin Trudeau up in Canada man uh
first off the idea that Ontario might
bring back a mask mandate masks do not
work you've heard it before and you'll
hear it again masks often people put on
mats first off they touch their face a
lot more they're always touching it
people literally can't hear you speak
you pull the mass down to talk to
somebody you guys get all that masks the
air comes out the top it goes down it
just doesn't work it does not work so if
you want to keep yourself in a plastic
bag and wrap Saran wrap around it and
tie it up and all that okay fine maybe
um he said the single best thing is to
make sure you're updated with your
vaccine and your boosters that's not
true the vaccine boosters basically
don't work which is why he's gotten
coveted several times now I know that
they feel like they all have to say the
same thing which is I'm so happy I got
it because I got a less intense version
of covid there's no studies proving that
please someone post the study that
proves that they all say it doesn't mean
it's true actually when
we were walking around the capitol
yesterday I was underneath the capital
rotunda and there's a there's a
basically an underground tunnel that you
walk from the Senate building to the
Capitol and we walked right by Michelle
wilenski it was scary Michelle it's
Rochelle Rochelle not Michelle wilinsky
Rochelle wilinsky of the CDC we we
almost touched it was weird
um don't like her very much and I do
have a tweet calling for her arrest that
has about a hundred thousand retweets I
don't think she likes me very much
either anyway no the single best thing
is not to get vacs and boosted you know
what the single best thing would be to
take care of yourself to eat right to
exercise to even when you're in Canada
get outside and get some air and get
some sunshine and some vitamin D and
live your life as you see fit the idea
that he's thinking about mandates again
and encouraging people to get vaccinated
when what about the myocarditis what
about the heart problems all of the
stuff you're a bad dude Justin Trudeau
and I don't like you very much and I
wish all all of my Canadian friends you
know a lot of Canadian people moving
down to Florida right now you know we
had the snowbirds much like the
Northeast people and the Midwest people
who come on down to Florida for their
Winters there's a lot of Canadians
coming down and I suspect a lot of them
are going to try to stay and I would be
doing that myself if I was a Canadian
right now let me talk to you about my
box and then we'll get to the questions
uh did you guys know that 60 of U.S pork
production comes from one company owned
by the Chinese and their Hogs are given
something called ractopamine which is
banned in 160 countries including China
yet you'll find it in your grocery aisle
right here there's a better way I'd like
to talk to you guys about moink that's
moo plus oink Mike delivers grass-fed
and grass-finished beef and lamb
pasteurized pork and chicken and
sustainable wild caught Alaskan salmon
straight to your door boink Farmers Farm
like our grandparents did and as a
result moink meat tastes like it should
because the Family Farm Does It Better
the moink difference is the difference
you can taste and you can feel good
knowing you're helping family farms stay
financially independent as well you
choose the meat delivered in every box
like rib eyes to chicken breasts to pork
chops to salmon fillets and much more I
recommend the bratwurst they just had it
this weekend plus you can cancel any
time my personal favorite is their filet
mignon Shark Tank host Kevin O'Leary
called moink's bacon the best bacon he's
ever tasted and ring doorbell founder
Jamie simenov jumped at the chance to
invest in moink plus they guarantee
you'll say oink oink I'm just so happy I
got moinked keep American farming going
by signing up at moinkbox.com Reuben
right now and listeners of this show get
a free filet mignon in every order for a
year that's one of the best filet mignon
you'll ever taste but for a limited time
m-o-i-n-k-box.com rubenmoinkbox.com
Reuben all right let's get into the
Community Q a I know we mixed it up
today a little political a little
personal
and a little caffeinated here we go
Bourne says if DeSantis became our next
president who would you trust to be the
next governor of Florida do you think
Florida could afford to lose descent so
look obviously Trump announcing is the
big thing Trump announcing also it's
super super early right like he I think
perhaps what happened here what caused
him to do this was that he really did
think the Red Wave was coming he thought
that he was going to capitalize it and
announce right after so he could take
all the credit for the Red Wave Red Wave
doesn't happen but he had already
basically laid the groundwork to make
the announcement so he went ahead and
did it
now that's one thing about Trump as far
as DeSantis again I don't know if he
wants to run I know he loves Florida and
I know he's doing a bang-up job here and
I also know that your state right now
just means more than the federal
government that's the way it was set up
it sounds weird it's like wait you don't
love all of America no I do love all of
America but I can affect uh Florida the
state that I live in more than the rest
of the country and and that's what you
can do in the state that you live in as
well or you can choose to leave right
like it's really it's as simple as that
although I get it's not easy and simple
to move but it's as simple as that like
making some decisions so that your life
and where you live and who you live
around and who you're voting for fits in
with what you think of the world so what
happens if DeSantis runs beats Trump and
now DeSantis is President who's going to
take over in Florida look Florida has
incredible infrastructure almost
everyone that I've met not even almost
everyone that I've met around uh
Governor DeSantis has been absolutely
spectacular it's an airtight team I
would say Byron Donalds who I just
interviewed I interviewed him on
Election night if you didn't see our
live stream on Election night we did a
quick mini interview it was loud and
people were cheering and going nuts and
then I just interviewed him uh here in
DC which will be up uh early next week
I'm being told uh he's excellent he's a
congressman from Southwest Florida which
was the area that was crushed by
Hurricane Ian that's the former buyers
Naples area he's a really bright young
voice he checks off some of the identity
politics stuff not that you guys care
about that I think he would be
interesting I think maybe Miami mayor
Francis Suarez would be interesting I
think our state CFO Jimmy Patronus might
be interesting I think there's a whole
bunch of people Kaylee mcinany I don't
know like there's a lot of good
Floridians you never know or DeSantis
makes it over to the White House and
then Trump becomes governor who who
knows Ray says what are your
Thanksgiving plans so Thanksgiving is
the one holiday that we try to host at
our house so uh that's uh with David's
family so his family mom
father-in-law soon enough I think I
probably just tip something off there
maybe you never know if anyone's
watching this from the family I have no
inside information it was just something
I said uh and uh brothers and sisters
and all that stuff uh and fortunately we
have a whole bunch of people that are
really fantastic chefs and cooks and
everything else including David of
course he's going to be a little
distracted with the kids uh so we it's a
team effort in the uh in the kitchen I'm
psyched this will be our first
Thanksgiving obviously in Florida and
I'm incredibly thankful for the state
that I live in so I'm psyched to have
everybody over and I also just
Thanksgiving to me is by far my favorite
holiday in that it's a it's a purely
American secular holiday designed for us
all to take a moment like stop fighting
for a moment and just realize you got
some food on the table you're hopefully
sitting with some people you'll love or
at least like and it's like it's pretty
good despite all the craziness and that
doesn't mean we gotta we can't fight to
make it better or we shouldn't we should
we should uh but there's a there's a
real decency to Thanksgiving that I that
I just appreciate I also appreciate
unbuckling the pants and laying on the
couch and taking six naps uh Lewin says
will Carrie Lake fight the fraud look
it's hard to know what the hell happened
in Arizona it almost felt like it was
like destined to go this crazy way right
because Carrie Lake was was the
politician in this entire cycle who was
talking about voter fraud more than
anyone else she was backing Trump on
fraud claims more than anybody else and
then it turns out that her state which
they had been doing work to make sure it
was going to be bad better this time
around that they turn out to be the ones
that it takes seven days to count the
votes uh Blake Masters who you guys know
my feelings I think he's a great dude
and I think he would have been a
fantastic Center he has conceded so is
what it is he has a bright future
whether it's in politics or or private
sector or whatever uh Carrie I I suspect
she's gonna fight that would be my guess
I mean it's within I think one percent
and I think she'll try to get some stuff
recounted and uh and we'll see what
happens but
more than anything else whether you like
Carrie whether you like Blake whether
you're happy about what happened or not
it's like we need to secure elections
this Dropbox stuff this early voting
stuff this bundling stuff and then
deciding suddenly that no we'll find out
maybe tomorrow actually it's going to be
three days oh it's six days later now
we'll announce even if it's all legit as
I keep saying even if even if there was
no fraud within that whatsoever although
I think the more time that goes on from
the when people cast their vote to when
it's announced they're you you're giving
room for fraud but even if there's no
for a big idea that you wait six days
and that all these things happen it puts
the idea in people's mind that it's
fraudulent or it's being messed with or
there's a little tomfoolery so that I
think is the problem uh Deb says do you
go Black Friday shopping usually I'm in
a post-fold uh post food coma and uh you
know some years I did over the years
like I remember when when everyone was
getting flat screen TVs for the first
time in New York City I remember putting
bundling up in the jacket going into a
wait in line on the upper west side to
get into Best Buy so I could fight with
uh with someone over uh over a flat
screen TV I mean what kind of world is
it that someone would walk up to
somebody and just punch them in the face
and take a 50-inch flat screen TV but I
did it I did what I had to do you know
what I mean so uh yeah so I've done it I
guess I'll do a little more probably
virtual and try to stay on Amazon just a
bit I'm really trying to get off the the
Amazon uh take that Amazon piece out of
me because uh it's too much stuff on
there Amy Says Dave help I'm stuck in
blue jersey and can't get to Florida or
Freedom anytime soon any advice on what
I can do to survive this dystopia that's
taking over my kids are infected thanks
to college out man 12 years of Catholic
School poof gone in four years at higher
ed oh man well
first off you know Jersey
uh last time the last jersey
gubernatorial race was pretty close it
was within a I think one percent so
Jersey almost went red uh but did not
Jersey also because of the proximity to
New York and tri-state area with
Connecticut it's like it's all driven by
New York so even if Jersey is a little
bit red it kind of feels like it's blue
because New York is blue
um what do you do
um hopefully you just show your kids
that you're a decent person and that
you're not a bigot and all of the things
that they're probably thinking about you
from the info that they're learning at
college right and if you do that then
hopefully some of the things that they
were taught in school before they were
infected will come back and then I would
say also I know you're saying you can't
leave but you really should think about
like if you're really out of whack over
there with if your beliefs are just out
of whack with the direction that your
town and city and state are going in you
just got to think about it uh Curtis
says enjoyed your Tim pool session the
other night what was the highlight of
the Congress conversation for you it's
totally fun doing Tim Poole the coolest
part for me by far is that Tim when Tim
started years ago and we kind of Rose
together Tim's become this sort of
massive you know he's got this massive
young I would say mostly male sort of
political cultural video game Skater
audience politics all weird stuff it's
kind of funky and weird what the coolest
part was I was just super proud of him
in some ways I kind of felt like an
older brother I think and I said to him
at the end I'm just so proud of what
he's built I mean he's got like 20
employees they've got this huge
operation over there they're expanding
they're doing all this stuff and it's
like when I met him he was this broke
little kid with his beanie and his
little handheld camera and he had
nothing and he worked and worked and
worked and he called out the BS where he
saw it and he actually was a journalist
he didn't have to put air quotes around
and it worked for him so the coolest
part was just seeing you know all I know
so many people that I've kind of grown
with and some of them then go nuts and
some of them some of them become
failures but when the succeed when the
successful ones who deserve success get
it it's awesome Freebird says Where Do
We Go From Here uh I sense you mean that
in some sort of political and or
existential uh sense I am going to
Hollywood Florida to the fox Patriot
Awards so if any of you are at the Hard
Rock Hotel over the next couple days
I'll be around come say hi Elizabeth
says I've noticed that when talking to
people both online in person they are
quick to anger and quick to insult how
do we get back to talking to each other
with respect after having helpful and
having helpful debates after the
political polarization of the last
several years and the rise of social
media well I hate to tell you Elizabeth
it is not going to be easy because with
Trump back in it's going to unearth a
whole bunch of stuff right and I think
in some ways
in some ways that's good right Trump has
a way of unearthing stuff getting people
to expose themselves getting the machine
to show you how nonsensical it is but it
also comes with a lot of emotional
baggage for people and it comes with it
with why did they call it Trump
derangement syndrome this thing where
everyone thinks the whole world revolves
around this guy so I think a lot of the
emotional stuff and craziness and
fighting we've just begun to get back
into it again it's also why whether
DeSantis gets in or not it's like just
don't go down that road with each other
I don't think it's desantis's motive but
I don't want Trump to go down that road
with him it's like Trump if you if you
want us to support you and a lot of us
like you and as I said there's a good
chance I'll vote for him we got to see
we have to see what happens
um but just the the mutually assured
destruction that I'm going to take out
anyone at whatever the cost might be I'm
worried about so what do you do you just
try to be a better person just try to
smile every now and again understand
that they don't know exactly what
they're saying which is why they're so
angry and go from there
Palmetto says we had our second boy in
August congratulations and I've noticed
a lot of little differences preferences
fussiness from the first child have you
noticed any differences between your two
boys yet hope you enjoyed DC so
obviously we had Justin in August and
then we had Luke in October so they're
two months to the day off from each
other which at three months and one
month it's like it's a pretty
significant difference uh Justin's
disposition is very very like kind of
chill and smiley and if this kid is has
eaten and if this kid has pooped he is
happy and he's good to go Luke is a
little more sensitive right he's a
little more like you gotta work with him
he's a little fussier but there's a
softness to him like uh
there's just like a goodness in him that
you can see so I think I think they're
gonna be a good match uh certainly for
each other and definitely for us uh Dave
says on the Tim pool show you said we
should all flee to Red States but if we
succeed power to the federal but if we
secede power to the federal government
the Dems will crush the red States and
overthrow the Constitution how do you
stop them from federal overreach at the
state level so yeah I don't know that I
went quite that far but basically what I
was saying was if enough of us go to the
red States the blue States will still
want stuff from the red States like the
red States really could separate I don't
mean Civil War or breaking up the union
I mean just taking care of their own
business taking care of their own house
getting their house in order I think the
red States could do that effectively I
think you're I think we're already
seeing it so whether you think I I it's
a good idea or not it's happening it's
happening in real time people are moving
and 550 000 people in the last couple
years left New York about 350 000 people
left California nobody's moving to those
places they're going to Red places and
they're making red places redder and
then us it makes blue States Bluer so
it's happening whether you like it or
not
um
the issue really is about the federal
government and what the federal
government will try to do you know the
Federal Government tried to send
election monitors into Florida on
Election Day and the Santa said no he
said this is the purview of the state
what do you what do you think you're
doing we have no doubt that our
elections are run fairly and the FEDS
couldn't get in so I think the states
are going to need to do more and more of
that because this this federal
government under Biden and the Dems
right now they want money and power and
control wherever they can get it and the
red states are going to have to figure
out what the parameters are what the
walls are to make sure that they can't
grab any more of those things Dawn says
how can we trust election results that
take a week to tally are they using
Common Core math they probably are using
Common Core math don't forget to carry
the one people
um how do we trust them we got to
tighten them up we got to tighten them
up it's the worst feeling in the world
when you vote and you don't feel like it
counted or you feel like they just drop
box it at the end or late voting or are
you waiting three days like that that's
why voting in Florida as I said it was
such a freaking pleasure fill out a
piece of paper show an ID walk over with
your own piece of paper to another man
at a box put your piece of paper in the
Box yourself feel like it actually was
all legit why is it that blue states
don't want that black people can get IDs
okay black people get on planes right
I'm pretty sure they do so it's it's
like these people want they either want
fraud in the system or they want the
appearance of fraud so that you just
feel like you have no power
it really is as simple as that Sam says
apparently abortion was a bigger issue
than we thought in 2022 do you think
it'll still have legs in 24 Democrats
love to run on it but now it almost
seems settled Roe v Wade has been
overturned many states had it on the
ballots this year helping Democrats win
but now what you know it's a little hard
to tell I suppose uh that abortion that
the Roe v Wade decision and the abortion
back to the states did maybe help the
Democrats to some degree right there's a
certain set of women that are voting on
that more than anything else and perhaps
young women got in and that was the
number one thing for them I think what
we're going to see though is that the
states are going to just do what the
states were doing before Roe v Wade
they're going to make decisions
accordingly 15 weeks here in Florida
it's a pretty solid one I think that's
that is once again I think that's the
blueprint for Most states to do things
fairly and with some degree of
compromise and then you make whatever
decision is best for yourself or you
donate money and time to help people so
that if you're really anti-abortion you
can help a girl who who's maybe thinking
about it like that puts Choice back in
the people's hands
um
so as far as 2024 I I suppose it will
still be an issue because are we going
to codify it are there going to be some
states that Outlaw it all together are
going to are we going to start seeing
busloads of young poor black women from
Alabama going to California for
abortions where they get an abortion and
a cookie from Gavin Newsom I suspect
over time the Optics of that are not
going to look that good but I would also
say that it's very unfortunate that
abortion is such a big issue for
everybody because it's it's a personal
and private decision obviously for the
most part and then there's the issue of
where the state has to protect life but
also there's so many I don't want to say
more important things but there are so
many functions that the government
really should be focused on all the time
like you know keeping you safe in the
border and police and things of that
nature and making sure the economy is
chuggling along that abortion just
becomes one of these culture War things
that envelopes the whole thing and and
it's messy M says why do you think so
many gen ziers are turning into leftists
even though some of their parents are
conservative because youth is wasted on
the young it's as simple as that young
people think that things are supposed to
be a certain way and because they think
it they think it should be and it should
be forever and they don't realize in
America we have grown up if you're
growing up in the last 40 years in
America the success and wealth
and privilege that you have as a free
person in a free society and it was very
easy to give away and then we give all
these kids all of their Awards whether
they come in first or they come in last
and they're confused about what actual
pride and hard work is they're confused
about what individual rights are and
that they think that the machine is
designed to just take care of them and
actually the machine is designed to
control them and and the culture and the
movies and all the stuff and that's why
we just got to keep building new things
parallel says how do you feel about
crypto well it's been a wacky week for
crypto in general because of this FTX
thing which was a centralized uh
centralized way of of taking in crypto
money which is nuts because crypto is
completely uncentralized decentralized
um I still think Bitcoin is completely
legit and we need more outside of the
system ways to be able to negotiate and
bargain with each other and exchange
goods and all of those things so crypto
still seems like uh Bitcoin still seems
like the right one as far as I'm
concerned but but crypto in general is
uh is under attack right now and uh you
know sometimes when things are under
attack it means that they're doing
something right and the powers that be
don't want it
um but I wouldn't dump all your crypto
if personally if I really wouldn't dump
all of it
um I would kind of wait it out because
also our economy is still feeling pretty
weird all right last question Ethan says
really like the hoodie you were wearing
on Tim pool the other night who makes it
that hoodie is from uh Marine layer
which has become one of my favorite
stores not sponsored in any way by the
Marine layer people I would love to love
their t-shirts love the the hoodies love
the shorts uh bathing suits they they've
just got great stuff they probably have
a shop in your town if not uh well they
definitely sell it online uh all right
guys as always subscribe if you have not
rumble.com Ruben report Ruben
report.locals.com if you want to play
along during the show uh part two of my
interview with former Wisconsin governor
Scott Walker is up right now and we have
no live show show at 11 A.M tomorrow but
we're going to be posting all these DC
interviews starting tomorrow
and then throughout next week and again
I'll be at the fox Patriot Awards
Hollywood Hard Rock Hotel for the next
couple of nights and then Gutfeld on
Friday night and I'm probably probably
had some other things while I'm there
anywho uh that is all from the swamp see
you soon